MICHALE FEE: Today we're
going to continue talking
about the topic of neural--
recurrent neural networks.
And last time, we talked about
recurrent neural networks
that give gain and suppression
in different directions
of the neural network space.
Today we're going to
talk about the topic
of neural integrators.
And neural integrators are
currently an important topic
in neuroscience because
they are basically
one of the most important
models of short-term memory.
So let me just say a
few words about what
short-term memory is.
So and to do that,
I'll just contrast it
with long-term memory.
So short-term memory
is memory that
just lasts a short period of
time on the order of seconds
to maybe a few tens
of seconds at most,
whereas long-term memories are
on the order of hours, or days,
or even up to an entire
lifetime of the animal.
A short-term memory
has a small capacity,
so just a few
items at a time you
can keep in short-term memory.
The typical number
would be something
like seven, the classic number,
sort of seven plus or minus
two.
You might have
heard this, so just
about the length
of a phone number
that you can remember
between the time
you look it up in the--
well, you know, we all have
phone numbers on speed dial
now, so we don't even remember
phone numbers anymore.
But in the old
days, you would have
to look it up in the
phone book and remember it
long enough to type it in.
OK, whereas long-term memories
have very large capacity,
basically everything that you
remember about all the work
in your classes that
you remember, of course,
for your entire life, not
just until the final exam.
Short-term memories are
thought to have an underlying
biophysical mechanism that
is the persistent firing
of neurons in a particular
population of neurons that's
responsible for
holding that memory,
whereas the biophysical
mechanism of long-term memories
is thought to be physical
changes in the neurons
and primarily in the
synapses that connect
neurons in a population.
So let me just show you a
typical short-term memory
task that's been used
to study neural activity
in the brain that's involved
in short-term memory.
So this is a task that has been
studied in nonhuman primates.
So the monkey sits in a
chair, stares at the screen.
There is a set of
spots on the screen
and a fixation
point in the middle,
so the monkey stares
at the fixation point.
One of those cues turns
on, so one of those spots
will change color.
The monkey has to maintain
fixation at that spot.
The cue turns off then.
So now the animal
has to remember
which cue was turned on.
And then some delayed
period later, which can be--
it's typically
between three to six
or maybe 10 seconds,
the animal--
the fixation cue goes away,
and that tells the animal
that it's time to then
look at the cued location.
And so in this interval between
the time when the cue turns off
and the animal has to look
at the location of that cue,
the animal has to remember the
direction in which that cue was
activated, or it has to remember
the location of that cue.
Now, if you record
from neurons in parts
of the prefrontal cortex
during this task, what you find
is that the neural
activity is fairly
quiet during the precue and the
cue period and then ramps up.
The firing rate
ramps up very quickly
and maintains a
persistent activity
during this delay period.
And then as soon as the
animal makes a saccade
to the remembered location,
then that neural activity
goes away because
the task is over
and the animal doesn't have to
remember that location anymore.
So that persistent
activity right there
is thought to be the neural
basis of the maintenance
of that short-term memory.
And you can see that the
activity of this neuron
carries information about which
of those cues was actually on.
So this particular
neuron is most active
when it was the cue in the
upper-left corner of the screen
that was active, and that neuron
shows no changes in activity
when the cued location
shows no change in activity
during the memory period,
during the delay period
when the cued location
was down and to the right.
So this neuron carries
information about which cue
is actually being remembered.
And of course, there
are different neurons
in this population of--
in this part of
prefrontal cortex.
And each one of
those neurons will
have a different
preferred direction.
And so by looking at a
population of neurons
then during the delay
period, you could figure out
and the monkey's brain can
remember which of those cues
was illuminated.
OK, so the idea of
short-term memory
is that you can have a stimulus
that is active briefly.
And then for some period of time
after that stimulus turns on,
there is neural
activity that turns on
during the presentation of that
stimulus and then stays on.
It persists for tens of seconds
after the stimulus actually
turns off.
So that's one notion
of short-term memory
and how neural
activity is involved
in producing that memory.
And the basic idea here
is that that stimulus
is in some way integrated
by the circuit,
and that produces a
step in the response.
And once that
stimulus goes away,
then that-- the integral
of that stimulus
persists for a long time.
All right, now, short-term
memory and neural integrators
are also thought to be
involved in a different kind
of behavior.
And that is the kind of
behavior where you actually
need to accumulate
information over time.
OK, so sometimes when
you look at a stimulus,
the stimulus can be very noisy.
And if you just look at it for
a very brief period of time,
it can be hard to
figure out what's
going on in that stimulus.
But if you stare
at it for a while,
you gradually get a
better and better sense
of what's going on
in that stimulus.
And so during that
period of time
when you're looking
at the stimulus,
you're accumulating
information about what's
going on in that stimulus.
And so there's a whole
field of neuroscience
that relates to this issue
of accumulating evidence
during decision-making.
OK, so let me show
you an example
of what that looks like.
So here's a different
kind of task.
Here's what it looks like
for a monkey doing this task.
The monkey fixates at a point.
Two targets come
up on the screen.
The monkey at the
end of the task
will have to saccade to one
or the other of those targets
depending on a
particular stimulus.
And a kind of stimulus that's
often used in tasks like this
is what's called a "random
dot motion stimulus."
So you have dots that
appear on the screen.
Most of them are
just moving randomly,
but a small number of them move
consistently in one direction.
So for example, a small
number of these dots
move coherently to the right.
And if the motion stimulus
is more to the right,
then the monkey has to then--
once that motion
stimulus goes away,
the monkey has to make a saccade
to the right-hand target.
Now, this task can
be very difficult
if a small fraction of the
dots are moving coherently
one way or the other.
And so what you can see is
that the percentage correct
is near chance when the
motion strength or the percent
coherence, the fraction of
the dots that are moving
coherently, is very small.
There's almost a--
there's a 50% chance
of getting the right answer.
But as the motion
strength increases,
you can see that the
monkey's performance
gets better and better.
And not only does the
performance get better,
but the reaction time
actually gets smaller.
So I'll show--
I found a movie of
what this looks like.
So this is from another lab
that set this up in rats.
So here's what this looks like.
So the rat is poking its
nose in a center port.
There's the rat.
There's a screen.
There's a center port
right in front of it
that the rat pokes its nose
in to initiate a trial.
And depending on whether
the coherent motion
is moving to the
right or left, the rat
has to get food reward
from one or the other port
to the left or right.
So here's what that looks like.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[BEEP]
[CLINK]
So this is a fairly
high-motion coherent stimulus,
so it's pretty easy to see.
But and you can see the animal
is performing nearly perfectly.
It's getting the right-- it's
making the right choice nearly
every time.
But for lower-coherence
stimuli, it becomes much harder,
and the animal gets a
significant fraction of them
wrong.
[END PLAYBACK]
OK, all right, I thought
that was kind of amusing.
Now, if you record
in the brain in--
also in parts of frontal
cortex, what you find
is that there are neurons.
And this is data from
the monkey again,
and this is from
Michael Shadlen's lab,
who's now at Columbia.
And what you find is that
during the presentation
of the stimulus
here, you can see
that there are neurons
whose activity ramps up
over time as the animal
is watching the stimulus.
And so what you can see here
is that these different traces,
so for example, the green
trace and the blue trace here,
show what the neurons are doing
when the stimulus is very weak.
And the yellow trace shows
what the neurons do when--
or this particular
neuron does when
the stimulus is very strong.
And so there's this
notion that these neurons
are integrating the evidence
about which way this--
these random dots are going
until that activity reaches
some sort of threshold.
And so this is
what those neurons
look like when you line
their firing rate up
to the time of the saccade.
And you can see that all of
those different trajectories
of neural activity ramp up until
they reach a threshold at which
point the animal
makes it's choice
about looking left or right.
And so the idea is that
these neurons are integrating
the evidence until
they reach a bound,
and then the animal
makes a decision.
The weaker the evidence is,
the weaker that evidence
accumulates.
The more weaker the coherence,
the more slowly the evidence
accumulates and the longer it
takes for that neural activity
to reach the threshold.
And so, therefore, the
reaction time is longer.
So it's a very powerful
model of accumulat--
evidence accumulation during
a decision-making task.
Here's another interesting
behavior that potentially
involves neural integration.
So this is navigation
by path integration
in a species of desert ant.
So these animals do
something really cool.
So they leave their nest,
and they forage for food.
But they're foraging for food.
It's very hot.
So they run around.
They look for food.
And as soon as they find
food, they head straight home.
And if you look at
their trajectory
from the time they leave
food, they immediately
head along a vector that
points them straight
back to their nest.
And so it suggests that
these animals are actually
integrat-- look.
The animal's doing all
sorts of loop-dee-doos,
and it's going all sorts
of different directions.
You'd think it would get lost.
How does it maintain?
How does it represent
in its brain
the knowledge of which direction
is actually back to the nest?
One possibility is that it uses
external cues to figure this
out, like it looks at the--
it sees little sand dunes
on the horizon or something.
You can actually rule out that
it's using sensor information
by after the point where it
finds food, you pick it up,
and you transport it
here to a different spot.
And the animal heads
off in a direction
that's exactly
the direction that
would have taken it back to the
nest had it been in the ori--
in the location
before you moved it.
So the idea is that somehow
it's integrating its distance,
and it's doing vector
integration of its distance
and direction over time.
OK, so lots of interesting
bits of evidence that the brain
does integration for different
kinds of interesting behaviors.
So today I'm going
to show you some--
another behavior that is
thought to involve integration.
And it's a simple
sensory motor behavior
where it's been possible to
study the circuitry in detail
that's involved in the neural
control of that motor behavior.
And the behavior is basically
the control of eye position.
And this group, this
was largely work done
that was done in David
Tank's lab in collaboration
with his theoretical
collaborators,
Mark Goldman and
Sebastian's Seung.
OK, so let me just show
you this little movie.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
OK, so these are goldfish.
Goldfish have an
ocular motor control
system that's very similar
to that in mammals and in us.
You can see that they
move their eyes around.
They actually make saccades.
And if you zoom in on their eye
and watch what their eyes do,
you can see that they
make discrete jumps
in the position of the eye.
And between those
discrete jumps,
the eyes are held
in a fixed position.
OK, now if you were to
anesthetize the eye muscles,
the eye would always
just sort of spring back
to some neutral location.
The eye muscles are
sort of like springs.
And in the absence
of any motor control
of any activation
of those muscles,
the eyes just relax
to a neutral position.
So when the eye moves
and it's maintained
at a particular
position, that has--
something has to
hold that muscle
at a particular tension
in order to hold
the eye at that position.
[END PLAYBACK]
So there are a set of muscles
that control eye position.
There's a whole set
of neural circuits
that control the tension
in those muscles.
And in these experiments,
the researchers
just focused on
the control system
for horizontal eye movements,
so motion, movement
of the eye from a more
lateral position to a more
medial position or rotation,
OK, so eye posi-- horizontal
eye position.
And so if you record
the position of the eye,
and look at-- this is sort of a
cartoon representation of what
you would see--
you see that the
eye stays stable
at a particular angle for a
while and then makes a jump,
stays stable, makes a
jump, and stays stable.
These are called
"fixations," and these
are called "saccades."
And if you record
from motor neurons
that innervate these
muscles, so these
are motor neurons in
the nucleus abducens,
you can see that the
neural activity is low,
the firing rate is low when
the eyes are more medial,
when the eyes are more forward.
And that firing
rate is high when
the eye is in a more
lateral position
because these are motor neurons
that activate the muscle that
pulls the eye more lateral.
Notice that there is a
brief burst of activity
here at the time
when the eye makes
a saccade to the-- into
the more lateral direction.
And there's a brief
suppression of activity
here when the eye
makes a saccade
to a more medial position.
Those saccades are driven
by a set of neurons,
by a brain area called "saccade
burst generator neurons."
And you can see
that those neurons
generate a burst
of activity prior
to each one of these saccades.
There are a set of neurons
that activate bursts--
activate saccades in
the lateral direction,
and there are other neurons
that activate saccades
in the medial direction.
And what you see is if you--
is that these saccade burst
neurons are actually--
generate activity
that's very highly
correlated with eye velocity.
So here you can see
recording from one
of these burst generator neurons
generates a burst of spikes
that goes up to about
400 hertz and lasts
about 100 milliseconds
during the saccade.
And if you plot
eye velocity along
with the firing rate of these
burst generator neurons,
you can see that those are
very similar to each other.
So these neurons are
generating a burst,
drives change in the velocity
of the neurons of the eye.
OK, so if we go
from neurons that
have activity that's
proportional to position,
and we have neurons
that have activity
that's proportional to velocity,
how do we get from velocity?
So the idea is that you
have burst saccade generator
neurons that project
to these neurons that
project to the muscles.
You have to have
something in between.
If you have neurons
that encode velocity
and you have neurons
that encode position,
you need something to
connect those to go
from velocity to position.
How do you get from
velocity to position?
If I have a trace of velocity,
can you calculate the position
by doing what?
AUDIENCE: Integrating.
MICHALE FEE: By integrating.
So the idea is that you
have a set of neurons here.
In fact, there's a part of
the brain, and in the goldfish
it's called "area one,"
that take that burst saccade
generator neuron
burst, integrate
it to produce a
position signal that
then controls eye position.
All right, so if you record from
one of these integrator neurons
while you're watching
eye position,
here's what that looks like.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
And so here's the
animal's looking
more lateral to the nose.
The goldfish's mouth is up here.
So that's more lateral.
That's moving more medial
there, more lateral, more--
[END PLAYBACK]
OK, so this neuron that
we were just watching
was recorded in
this area, area one.
Those neurons project
to the motor neurons
that actually innervate
the muscles to control
eye position.
And they receive inputs from
these burst generator neuron.
OK, so if you look at
the activity of one
of these integrator
neurons, that's
a spike train during
a series of saccades,
and fixations is a
function of time.
This trace shows the average
firing rate of that neuron.
This is just smoothed over
time, so you're just averaging
the firing rate in some window.
You can see that the
firing rate steps up,
that the firing rate jumps
up during these saccades
and then maintains a stable,
persistent firing rate.
So the way-- think about this
is that this persistent firing
right here is maintaining a
memory, a short-term memory
of where the eye is, and
that sends an output that
puts the eye at that position.
OK, and so just
like we described,
we can think of these
saccade burst generator
neurons as sending an
input to an integrator that
then produces a step
in the position,
and then the burst
generator input
is zero during the [INAUDIBLE].
So the integrator doesn't
change when the input is zero.
And then there's
effectively a negative input
that produces decrement
in the eye position.
OK, we started talking last
time about a neural model that
could produce this
kind of integration.
And I'll just walk through
the logic of that again.
So our basic model of
a neuron is a neuron
that has a synaptic input.
If we put a brief
synaptic input,
remember we described how our
firing rate model of a neuron
will take that input,
integrate it briefly, and then
the activity, the firing rate
of that neuron will decay away.
So we can write down an
equation for this single neuron,
tau dv/dt is equal
to minus v. That's
due to this intrinsic
decay plus an input.
And that input is
synaptic input.
But what we want, a system where
when we put in a brief input,
we get a persistent activity
instead of a decaying activity.
And I should just
remind you that we
think of this intrinsic
decay and this intrinsic leak
as having a time constant
of order 100 milliseconds.
And I should have
pointed out actually
that in this system here, these
neurons have a persistence
of order of tens of seconds.
So even in the
dark, the goldfish
is making saccades to
different directions.
And when it makes a
saccade, that eye position
stays stable for--
it can stay stable
for many seconds.
And if you can do
this in humans,
you can ask a person
to saccade in the dark
and try to hold their eyes
steady at a given position,
and a person will be able
to saccade to a position.
Just you can imagine
closing your eyes
and saccading to a position.
Humans can hold
that eye position
for about 10 or 20 seconds.
So that's sort of
the time constant
of this integrator
in the primate,
so that's also consistent with
nonhuman primate experiments.
OK, so this has a very
long time constant.
But we want a neural model that
can model that very long time
constant of this
persistent activity that
maintains eye position.
All right, but the intrinsic
time constant of neurons
is about 100 milliseconds.
So how do we get from
a single neuron that
has a time constant
of 100 milliseconds
to a neural integrator that can
have a time constant of tens
of seconds?
All right, one way to do that
is by making a network that
has recurrent connections.
And you remember
that the simplest
kind of recurrent network is
a neuron that has an autapse.
But more generally,
we'll have neurons
that connect to other neurons.
Those other neurons
connect to other neurons.
And there are feedback loops.
This neuron connects
to that neuron.
That neuron connects
back, and so on.
And so the activity of this
neuron can go to other neurons,
and then come back, and excite
that neuron again, and maintain
the activity of that neuron.
So we developed a method for
analyzing that kind of network
by [INAUDIBLE] a
recurrent weight
matrix, recurrent
connection matrix
that describes the connections
to a neuron A in this network
from all the other
neurons in the network,
A prime, input to neuron
A from neuron A prime.
And now we can write down
a differential equation
for the activity of
one of these neurons.
dv/dt is minus v that
produces this intrinsic decay,
plus synaptic input from all
the other neurons in the network
summed up over all
the other neurons
plus this external burst input.
So how do we make
a neural network
that looks like an integrator?
But how do we do that?
If we want our neuron, the
firing rate of our neuron
to behave like an
integrator of its input,
what do we have to
do to this equation
to make this neuron
look like an integrator?
So what do we have to do?
To make this neuron
look like an integrator,
it would just be tau
dv/dt equals burst input.
Right?
So in order to make this
network into an integrator,
we have to make sure that
these two terms sum to zero.
So in other words, the
feedback from other neurons
in the network
back to our neuron
has to exactly balance the
intrinsic leak of that neuron.
Does that makes sense?
OK, so let's do that.
And when you do
that, this is zero.
The sum of those
two terms is zero.
And now the derivative of
the activity of our neuron
is just equal to the input.
So our neuron now
integrates the input.
So now the firing rate of our
neuron, so there should be a v
is equal to 1 over tau, the
integral of burst input.
So we talked last time
about how you analyze
recurrent neural networks.
We start with a
recurrent weight matrix.
So again, these Ms describe
the recurrent weights
within that network.
We talked about how if
M is a symmetric matrix,
connection matrix, then we can
rewrite the connection matrix
as a rotation matrix times
a diagonal matrix times
a rotation, the inverse
rotation matrix,
so phi transpose lambda
phi where, again,
lambda is a diagonal matrix,
and phi is a rotation matrix
that's [INAUDIBLE] two, in
this case, in the case of two--
a two-neuron network,
then this rotation matrix
has as its columns
the two basis vectors
that we can now use
to rewrite the firing
rates of this work in terms
of modes of the network.
So we can multiply
the firing rate vector
of this network
times phi transpose
to get the firing rates
of different modes
of that network.
And what we're
doing is essentially
rewriting this recurrent network
as set of independent modes,
independent neurons,
if you will,
that described the modes
with recurrent connectivity
only within that mode.
So we're rewriting that network
as a set of only autapses.
And the diagonal
elements of this matrix
are just the strength of
the recurrent connections
within that mode.
All right, so for a network
to behave as integrator,
most of the eigenvalues
should be less than 1,
but one eigenvalue should be 1.
And in that case, one
mode of the network
becomes an integrating
mode, and all
of the other modes
of the network
have the property that their
activity decays away very,
very rapidly.
So I'm going to go through
this in more detail
and show you examples.
But for a network to
behave as an integrator,
you want one integrating mode,
one eigenvalue close to 1
and most of the-- all
of the other eigenvalues
much less than 1.
So if you do that,
then you have one mode
that has the following equation
that describes its activity,
tau, and let's say that's lambda
1 that has eigenvalue of 1.
So tau dc1/dt, dc/dt
equals minus c,
that's the intrinsic
decay of that mode,
plus lambda 1 c1
plus burst input.
And if lambda 1 is equal to 1,
then those two terms cancel.
Then the feedback
balances the leak,
and that mode becomes
an integrating mode.
So when you have a burst input,
the activity in that mode
increases.
It steps up to some new value.
And then between the burst
inputs, that mode obeys--
the activity of that mode obeys
the following differential
equation.
There's no more burst
input between the bursts.
dc/dt is just equal to lambda
minus 1 over tau times c1.
And if lambda is equal to
1, then this, then dc/dt
equals zero, and the
activity is constant.
Does that makes sense?
Any questions about that?
Yes, Rebecca.
AUDIENCE: OK, so why
does it [INAUDIBLE]
need to balance [INAUDIBLE]
MICHALE FEE: Yes,
that's exactly right.
If this is not true,
if, let's say that--
what happens if
lambda is less than 1?
If lambda is less than 1, then
this quantity is negative.
So if lambda is 0.5, let's
say, then this is 0.5 over tau,
minus 0.5 over tau.
So dc/dt is some negative
constant times c.
Which means if c is positive,
then dc/dt is negative,
and c is decaying.
Does that makes sense?
If lambda is bigger than 1,
then this constant is positive.
So if c is positive,
then dc/dt is positive,
and c continues to grow.
So it's only when
lambda equals 1
that dc/dt is zero
between the burst inputs.
OK, so let's look at a
really simple model where
we have two neurons.
There's autapse recurrence
here, but it's easy to add that.
And let's say that the weights
between these two neurons
are 1.
So we can write down
the weight matrix.
It's just 0, 1; 1, 0
because the diagonals,
the diagonals are
0, OK, 0, 1; 1, 0.
The eigenvalue equation
looks like this.
You know that because
the diagonal elements are
equal to each other and the
off-diagonal elements are
equal to each other because
it's a symmetric matrix, then
the eigenvalue, the
eigenvectors are always what?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MICHALE FEE: 45 degrees,
OK, so 1, 1 and minus 1, 1.
So our modes of
the network, if we
look in this state space
of v1 versus v2, the two
modes of the network are in
the 1, 1 direction and the 1,
minus 1 direction.
What are the eigenvalues
of this network?
OK, so for a matrix like
this with equal diagonals
and equal off-diagonals,
the eigenvalues
are just the diagonal
elements plus or minus
the off-diagonal element.
I'll just give you a hint.
This is going to be very
similar to a problem
that you'll have on the final.
So if you have any questions,
feel free to ask me.
OK?
OK, so the eigenvalues
are plus or minus 1.
They're 1 and minus 1.
And it turns out
for this case, it's
easy to show that the
value for this mode is 1,
and the eigenvalue for
this mode is minus 1.
And you can see it.
It's pretty intuitive.
This network likes to be active
such that both of these neurons
are both on.
When that neuron's on,
it activates that neuron.
And so this network really likes
it when both of those neurons
are active.
And that's the amplifying
direction of this network.
And the eigenvalue value is
such that the amplification
in that direction is large
enough that it turns that
into an integrating mode.
All right, so I'll show
you what that looks like.
So the eigenvalues
again are 1 and minus 1.
If you just do that
matrix multiplication,
you'll see that that's true.
lambda is 1, and
lambda is minus 1.
You can just read this off.
This first eigenvalue
here is the eigenvector
for the first mode.
This eigenvalue
is the eigenvalue
for that vector for that mode.
So here's what this looks like.
So this mode is the
integrating mode.
This mode is a decaying
mode because the eigenvalue
is much less than 1.
And what that means
is that no matter
where we start on this
network, the activity
will decay rapidly
toward this line.
Does that makes sense?
No matter where you
start the network,
activity in this
direction will decay.
Any state of this network
that's away from this line
corresponds to activity of this
mode, and activity of that mode
decays away very rapidly.
So no matter where you
start, the activity
will decay to this
diagonal line.
So let me just ask
one more question.
So if we put an input
in this direction,
what will the network do?
So let's turn on an input in
this direction and leave it on.
What does the network do?
Rebecca?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MICHALE FEE: Good.
So we're going to turn it
on and leave it on first.
The answer you gave is the
answer to my next question.
The answer is when you put that
input on and you turn it off,
then the activity
goes back to zero.
That's exactly right.
But when you put the input--
when you turn the input
in this direction on,
the network will--
the state will move
in this direction
and reach a steady state.
When you turn the input off, it
will decay away back to zero.
If we put an input in this
direction, what happens?
AUDIENCE: It just
keeps going on.
MICHALE FEE: It just
keeps integrating.
And then we turn the input off.
What happens?
AUDIENCE: It [INAUDIBLE]
MICHALE FEE: It
stops, and it stays.
Because the network
activity in this direction
is integrating
any input that has
a projection in this direction.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So [INAUDIBLE]
steady state [INAUDIBLE]
to F1, so if anything that
has any component in the F1
direction will either
grow or [INAUDIBLE]
over 90 degrees [INAUDIBLE] F1?
MICHALE FEE: Yep.
AUDIENCE: Would it [INAUDIBLE]
MICHALE FEE: Like here?
So if you put an input
in this direction,
what is the component
of that input
in the integrating direction?
If we put an input
like this, what--
it has zero component in
the integrating direction,
and so nothing gets integrated.
So you put that input.
The network responds.
You take the input away, and
it goes right back to zero.
If you put an input in this
direction, all of that input
is in this direction,
and so that input just
gets integrated by the network.
OK?
What happens if you put an
input in this direction?
Then it has a little
bit of-- it has
some projection
in this direction
and some projection
in this direction.
The network will respond to
the input in this direction.
But as soon as that input goes
away, that will decay away.
This, the projection
in this direction,
will continue to be integrated
as long as the input is there.
So let me show you
what that looks like.
So I'm going to show
you what happens when
you put an input vertically.
What that means, input
in this direction
means that we have
an input to H1.
Input to this neuron is 0, but
the input to that neuron is 1.
That corresponds to H0 being--
H1 direction being 0,
and the H2 direction
being 1 that has a
projection in this direction
and this direction.
And here's what
the network does.
OK, sorry.
I forgot which way it was going.
So you can see
that the network is
responding to the input
in the H1 direction.
But as soon as that
input goes away,
the activity of the
network in this direction
goes away as soon as
the input goes away.
But it's integrating the
projection in this direction.
So you can see it
continues to integrate.
And than you put an input
in the opposite direction,
it integrates until the input
goes away, and it stops there.
OK, let me play that again.
Does everyone get a sense
for what's going on?
So now we have a input
that has a projection
in the minus F1 direction.
And so it's the network
is just integrating
that negative number.
OK, is that clear?
OK, all right, so that's
a neural integrator.
It's that simple.
It has one mode that
has an eigenvalue of 1.
And all of its other modes
have small eigenvalues
or a negative.
OK, so notice that no
matter where you start,
this network evolves.
As long as there's no
input, that network
just relaxes to this line,
to a state along that line.
So that line is what we call
an "attractor" of the network.
The state of the network
is attracted to that line.
Once the state is sitting on
that line, it will stay there.
So that kind of attractor is
called a "line attractor."
That distinguishes it from
other kinds of attractors
that we'll talk in
the next lecture.
We'll talk about when there are
particular points in the state
space that are attractors.
OK, no matter where you start
the network around that point,
the state evolves
toward that one point.
OK, so the line of
the line attractor
corresponds to the direction
of the integrator mode,
of the [INAUDIBLE] mode.
So we can kind of see
this attractor in action.
If we record from two
neurons in this integrator
network of the goldfish
during this task, if you will,
where the [INAUDIBLE] saccades
to different directions,
so here's what that looks like.
So again, we've got two neurons
recorded simultaneously,
and we're following the
[INAUDIBLE] rate [INAUDIBLE]
versus [INAUDIBLE].
And Marvin the Martian
here is indicating
which way the goldfish
is looking [INAUDIBLE]..
OK, any questions about that?
So the hypothesis is that--
so I should mention that there--
I didn't say this before.
There are about a
couple hundred neurons
in that nucleus in area one
that connect to each other, that
contact each other.
What's not really known yet--
it's a little hard to prove,
but people are working on it.
What's not known yet is
whether the connections
between those neurons have
the right synaptic strength
to actually give you lambda,
give you an eigenvalue of 1
in that network.
So it's still kind
of an open question
whether this model is
exactly correct in describing
how that network works.
But Tank and others in
the field are working
on proving that hypothesis.
You can see that one
of the challenges
of this model for this
persistent activity
is that in order
for this network
to maintain persistent
activity, that feedback
from these other neurons back
to this neuron have to be--
have to exactly match the
intrinsic decay of that neuron.
And if that feedback
is too weak,
you can see that lambda
is slightly less than 1.
What happens is that neural
activity will decay away
rather than being persistent.
And if the feedback
is too strong,
that neural activity
will run away,
and it will grow exponentially.
So you can actually see evidence
of these two pathological cases
in neural integrators.
So let's see what that kind
of mismatch of the feedback
would look like in the behavior.
So if you have a
perfect integrator,
you can see that the--
you'll get saccades.
And then the eye
position between saccades
will be exactly flat.
The eye position
will be constant,
which means the
derivative of eye position
will be zero between
the saccades.
And it will be zero no matter
what eye position the animal
is holding its eyes.
So we can plot the
derivative of eye position
as a function of eye
position, and that
should be zero everywhere if
the integrator is perfect.
Now, what happens if
the integrator is leaky.
Now you can see
that, in this case,
the eye is constantly rolling
going back toward zero.
So but if the eye
is already at zero,
then the derivative
should be close to zero.
If the eye is far
away from zero,
then the derivative should be--
if the eye position
is very positive,
you can see that this
leak, this leaky integrator
corresponds to the
derivative being negative.
So if e is positive, then
the derivative is negative.
If e is negative, then the
derivative is positive.
And that corresponds to
a situation like this.
Positive eye
position corresponds
to negative derivative.
And you can see
that the equation
for the activity of this
mode which then translates
into eye position is just e to
the minus a constant times t.
If you have an
unstable integrator,
if this lambda is
greater than 1,
then positive eye positions will
produce a positive derivative,
and you get x runaway
growth of the eye position,
and that corresponds to
a situation like this--
positive eye position, positive
derivative, negative eye
position, negative derivative.
And then that equation for
that situation is either
the plus constant times t.
All right, so you can actually
produce a leaky integrator
in the circuit by injecting a
little bit of local anesthetic
into part of that nucleus.
And so what would that do?
You can see that if
you inject lidocaine
or some other
inactivator of neurons
into part of that network,
it would reduce the feedback
connections onto the
remaining neurons.
And so lambda
becomes less than 1,
and that produces
a leaky integrator
when you do that manipulation.
So this experiment is
consistent with the idea
that feedback
within that network
is required to produce that
stable, persistent activity.
Now, you can actually
find cases where
there are deficits in
the ocular motor system
that are associated with
unstable integration.
And this is called
congenital nystagmus.
So this is a human patient
with this condition.
And the person is being
told to try to fixate
at a particular position.
But you can see
that what happens
is their eyes sort of
run away to the edges,
to the extremes of eye position.
So they can fixate briefly.
The integrator
kind of runs away,
and their eyes run to the
edges, to the extremes
of the range of eye position.
And it's thought that that
one hypothesis for what's
going on there is that the
ocular motor integrator is
actually in an
unstable configuration,
that feedback is too strong.
So exactly how
precisely do you need
to set that feedback in order
to produce a perfect integrator?
So you can see that the
getting a perfect integrator
requires that lambda
minus 1 is equal to 0.
So lambda is equal to 1.
But if lambda is slightly
different from 1,
we can actually estimate
what the time constant
of the integrator would be.
So you can see that
the time constant
is really tau over lambda minus
1, tau over lambda minus 1.
So given the intrinsic
time constant tau n,
you can actually estimate how
close lambda has to be to 1
to get a 30-second
time constant, OK?
And that turns out to
be extremely close to 1.
In order to go from a
100-millisecond time
constant to a 30-second
time constant,
you need a factor of 300 or,
if the neural time constant
is even shorter, maybe
even 3,000 precision
in setting lambda equal to 1.
So this is actually one of the
major criticisms of this model,
that it can be hard to
imagine how you would actually
set the feedback in
a recurrent network
so precisely to get a
lambda equal to give you
time constants on the
order of 30 seconds.
Does anybody have any ideas
how you might actually do that?
What would happen?
Let's imagine what would
happen if we were--
we make saccades constantly.
We make several
saccades per second,
not including the
little microsaccades
that we make all the time.
But when we make a
saccade, what happens
to the image on the retina?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MICHALE FEE: Yeah, so and if
we make a saccade this way,
the image on the retina looks
like the world is going whoosh,
like this.
And as soon as it
stops and our eyes--
if our integrator is perfect
when the saccade ends,
our eyes are at a
certain position.
What happens to the
image on the retina?
If our eyes make a
saccade, and stop, and stay
at a certain position and
the velocity is zero, then
what happens to the
image on the retina?
It becomes stationary.
So but if we had a problem
with our integrator--
let's say that our
integrator was unstable.
So we make a saccade
in this direction,
but our integrator's unstable,
so the eyes keep going.
Then what would the
image on the retina look
like if we would have a motion
of the image across the retina
during the saccade?
And then if our
eyes kept drifting,
the image would keep going.
If we had a leaky integrator
and we make a saccade,
the image of the
world could go whoosh,
and then it would
start relaxing back
as the eyes drift back to zero.
So the idea is that when we're
walking around making saccades,
we have immediately feedback
about whether our integrator is
working or not.
And so, OK, I'm
going to skip this.
So the idea is that we can use
that sensory feedback that's
called "retinal
slip," image slip,
to give feedback about
whether the integrator is
leaky or unstable and use that
feedback to change lambda.
So if we make a
saccade this way,
the image is going
to go like this.
And now if that image starts
slipping back, what does that
mean we want to do?
What do we need to do to
our integrator, our synapses
in our recurrent network
if after we make a saccade,
the image starts slipping
back in the direction
that it came from?
We need to strengthen it.
That means we have
a leaky integrator.
We would need to
strengthen or make
those connections within
the integrator network more
excitatory.
And if we make a saccade this
way, the world goes like this
and then the image
continues to move,
it would mean our
integrator is unstable.
The excitatory connections
are too strong.
And so we would have a
measurement of image slip
that would tell us to
weaken those connections.
A lot of evidence that
this kind of circuitry
exists in the brain and that
it involves the cerebellum.
David Tank and his
colleagues set out
to test whether this
kind of image slip
actually controls the
recurrent connections
or controls the state
of the integrator,
whether you can use
image slip to control
whether the integrator
network is unstable or leaky,
whether that feedback
actually controls it.
Rebecca.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
is the [INAUDIBLE]
between slip and
overcompensation
with [INAUDIBLE] versus unstable
integrator, the direction of
[INAUDIBLE]
MICHALE FEE: Yes, exactly.
So if we make a
saccade this way,
the world on-- the image on
the retina is going to, whoosh,
suddenly go this way.
But then if the image goes--
OK, in the unstable
case, the eyes
will keep going, which means the
image will keep going this way.
So you'll have--
I don't know what sign
you want to call that,
but here, it's they
did a sign flip.
Here the case of decay.
So dE/dt is less than zero.
That means that the
eyes are going back,
which means that after
you make a saccade,
the image goes this way, and
then it starts sliding back.
AUDIENCE: So it'll return to--
MICHALE FEE: Return, yeah.
So if dE/dt is negative,
that means it's leaky.
The image slip will be positive.
And then you use
that positive image
slip to increase the
weight of the synapses.
So you change the synaptic
weights in your network
by an amount that's
proportional to
the negative of the
derivative of eye
position, which is
read out as image slip.
OK, is that clear?
OK, so they actually
did this experiment.
So they took a goldfish, head
fixed it, put it in this arena.
They made a little--
you put a little coil
on the fish's eye.
So this is a standard procedure
for measuring eye position
in primates, for example.
So you can put a little coil
on the eye that measures--
you measure-- OK, so you put
a little coil on the eye,
and you surround the fish with
oscillating magnetic fields.
So you have a big coil
outside the fish on this side,
another coil on this side, a
coil on the top and bottom,
and a coil on front and back.
And now you run AC current
through those coils.
And now by measuring how
much voltage fluctuation
you get in this
coil, you can tell
what the orientation
of that coil is.
Does that makes sense?
So now you can
read that out here
and get a very accurate
measurement of eye position.
And so now when the
fish makes a saccade,
you can read out which
direction the saccade was.
And immediately
after the saccade,
you can make this spot,
so there's a like a disco
ball up there that's on a
motor that produces spots
on the inside of
the planetarium.
Notice the fish makes a
saccade in this direction.
What you do is you make
the spots drift back,
drift in the direction as though
the eyes were sliding back,
as though the
integrator were leaky.
Does that make sense?
So you can fool the
fish's ocular motor system
into thinking that its
integrator is leaky.
And what do you think happens?
After about 10 minutes
of that, you then
turn all the lights off.
And now the fish's
integrator is unstable.
So here's what that looks like.
There's the spots on the inside.
There's the disco ball.
That's a overview picture
showing the search coils
for the eye position
measurement system.
And here's the control.
That's what the fish--
the eye position looks
like as a function of time.
So you have saccade,
fixation, saccade, fixation.
That right there, anybody
know what that is?
That's the fish blinking.
So it blinks.
Give feedback-- OK, here
they did it the other way.
So they give their feedback
as if the network is unstable,
and you can make
the network leaky.
If you give feedback as
if the network is leaky,
so it makes a
saccade, and now you
drift the spots in the direction
as if the eye were sliding back
to neutral position, and now you
can make the network unstable.
So it makes a
saccade, and the eyes
continue to move in the
direction of the saccade.
Saccade, and it runs away.
Any questions about that?
So that learning
circuit, that circuit
that implements that change
in the synaptic weights
of the integrator
circuit, actually involves
the cerebellum.
There's a whole
cerebellar circuit
that's involved in
learning various parameters
of the ocular motor
control system
that produces these
plastic changes.
OK, so that's-- are
there any questions?
Because that's it.
So I'll give you
a little summary.
So the goldfishes do integrals.
There's an integrator
network in the brain
that takes burst inputs
that drive saccades.
And the integrator integrates
those bursts and produces
persistent changes in the
activity of these integrator
neurons that then drive the
eyes to different positions
and maintain that eye position.
So we've described a
neural mechanism, which
is this recurrent network,
a recurrent network
has one eigenvalue that's 1 that
produces an integrating mode,
and all the other
eigenvalues are close to--
are less than 1 or negative.
The model is not
very robust if you
have to somehow hand-tune
all of those [INAUDIBLE]
to get a lambda of 1.
But there is a mechanism
that uses retinal slip
to tell whether that eigenvalue
is set correctly in the brain
and feeds back to adjust
that eigenvalue to produce
the upper lambda, the proper
eigenvalue in that circuit
so that it functions
as an integrator
and using visual feedback.
And I just want
to mention again,
so I actually got
most of these slides
from Mark Goldman
when he and I actually
used to teach an early
version of this course.
We used to give lectures
in each other's courses,
and this was his lecture.
He later moved to--
he was at Wellesley.
So we would go back and forth
and give these lectures.
But he moved to Davis.
So now I'm giving
his lecture myself.
And the theoretical work
was done by Sebastian Seung
and Mark Goldman.
The experimental work was
done in David Tank's lab
in collaboration with
Bob Baker at NYU.
OK, and so next time, we're
going to-- so today we talked
about short-term memory using
neural networks as integrators
to accumulate information
and to perform--
to generate line attractors that
can produce a short-term memory
of continuously graded
variables like eye position.
Next time, we're going to talk
about using recurrent networks
that have eigenvalues
greater than 1
as a way of storing
short-term discrete memories.
And those kinds of networks
are called Hopfield networks,
and that's what we're going
to talk about next time.
OK, thank you.